this is a student initiated event what
as it should be this is something that
we applaud and we're delighted to be
able to host this happen very quickly
the energy and the organizational
capacity that went into it I am I'm
talking about you know within less than
a week this thing was organized and it's
at the beginning of a series of things
that we presumably and hopefully we will
come come to together it is to say there
is no snow grand plan inside it is the
event is as these things because it is
in the university they it has to be
sponsored by officially by some
University body so it's a co-sponsor by
the Heyman center of the humanities the
Institute for a comparable in society
and Institute for religion culture and
public life we are sharing the sponsor
duties and I am by the way stats
Gregorius I am a professor compared
literature the Institute of comparators
in society I'm going I de that i'm not
going to reduce myself or my colleagues
according to our achievements because
this is really not about us it's really
about us having a conversation and that
we will speak very little we promise
each other we'll keep our comments the
minimum so that we can in fact have this
conversation in any case I you know I
teach courses in the democracy modernity
secularism humanism that sort of thing
it within the Institute to my left here
is Nadia bonatti who's professor coblos
chair political theory at the political
science department she teaches political
theory contemporary political thought
but also the study of democracy and
anti-democratic movements as well
traditions from antiquity to the present
and next to her a duration I do who is
assistant professor of economics and he
works on development economics
lyrical economy in labor economics and I
will introduce Sasuke who in her absence
we all know her works is Robert lint
professor of sociology and co-chair of
the committee global thoughts and one of
the premier thinkers about globalization
and its dimensions immigration global
technologies and of course global cities
which is a term that she has invented we
will proceed sure s first Nadia second
and Sasuke comes third and I will say a
thing or two at the end since I get that
have that advantage of moderate ok all
right we got it we can hear me ok so I
actually you know I everyone has this
idea that economists are this
ridiculously reactionary discipline and
I you know that may or may not be true
but it's I think it's in fact that you
know from there's a lot of streams of
sort of mainstream economics that that
would make nothing that sort of
completely rationalized everything that
we've seen in in this occupation so if
you just pick some random country with
this kind of inequality and then gave it
a massive sudden increase in unemployed
young college grads with a training in
the whole history of radical thought at
various liberal arts colleges you would
think wow that's a place that's really
ripe for social unrest and oh look here
we are and so I don't think there's
anything particularly surprising about
why Occupy Wall Street I don't think
that's a hard question you know I think
in 2008 I was giving a talk at the
minute Venezuelan Ministry of Planning
and they asked me at what point will the
economic crisis turn into a social
crisis and I said never underestimate
the ability of American citizens to take
punishment without complaining and and
but here we are complaining now the
puzzle i think is really why it took
three years and it took a pile of
scruffy kids and pagans and energies to
actually set this off and i think that's
a little bit partly coming out of this
fact that took an obama victory and
subsequent lack of any real policy
change so there's that but there's also
the tactical diffusion that
up and through these networks of
activists both in New York that then had
contacts in Tahrir in Greece in Tunisia
and that this tactic of the General
Assembly got diffused and developed
through these like international links
and that's something that you know it
got tried here and it took off and it
but it took a while for it to get
developed abroad and then to get to get
imported here okay so that's my point
one as why Occupy Wall Street isn't that
much of a puzzle the next not that much
of a puzzle is why Wall Street and you
know of I think a variety of evidence I
know I don't know anybody who thinks
that this is not true that the top one
percent of income is pretty much driven
by the financial sector and in fact
there's this lovely graph that you can
show about the index of financial
deregulation and and income going
into finance and it pretty much you know
could tracks fairly well in the time
series and it's important to realize
that finance is particularly funny right
it's a it's a claim on a future
uncertain economy and it's you know we
would call these things commodities and
then we buy and sell them but they're
really figments of our institutions and
laws and in 2008 we sort of realized in
the middle of this financial crisis that
actually all of this is up for grabs
that all of this can be renegotiated and
it's actually brute political power that
decides whose balance sheets get bailed
out and whose balance sheets don't get
bailed out and so and you know and so
there's a so then we also then sort of
see who's got the power to renegotiate
these financial crisis and renegotiate
the nature of financial property and you
know there's a hint it's not homeowners
and then further in finance when we
think about the kinds of policies that
are effectively insulated from citizens
it's really monetary policy its
financial regulation and it's
redistribute of policy more generally so
I think there's a overwhelming a very of
evidence from political economy and that
suggests that yes the Fed is distinctly
biased towards the banking industry that
yes the financial industry has been very
effective at capturing financial
regulation and that yes generically the
interest of politicians tends to report
respond to that of the richer
constituents
okay so when you've got this sort of
realm of policy that's roughly that's
pretty insulated from from citizen
control well then that starts that lets
us think about Occupy Wall Street is
like a democratization movement so it's
about bringing these sort of realms of
policy that are not in the realm that
are sort of generally insulated from
from popular control into the realm of
okay let's put them on the table as
something that we can that we can talk
about and because they're not on the
table in the formal political system it
takes Street politics to put them on the
table and but Street politics is is is
unpredictable and volatile and you can
only ever mobilize people for very short
periods of time and so you know we have
this literature and formal political
economy on how democratization movements
look and they generally temporarily
mobilize and then the government can
respond either by repressing them as in
Oakland or reforming trying to offer a
few policy fixes or by democratizing and
the difference between a reform and a
democratization is that a reform can be
reversed later on so that you can get
something today but the but it can be
reversed tomorrow and the thing that's
different about a democratization is
that when you win it you don't just
change the policy today you change your
ability to change policies tomorrow and
so that's what makes democratization
kind of the big stakes from from this
kinds of from this kind of mobilization
and so this explains I think a little
bit of the splits inside Occupy Wall
Street while you have the people that
want to cash in the political power
today and win a jobs program or debt
relief or put it into the Democratic
Party but then you have the the
wild-eyed kids that are like no we're
going to hold it and keep holding it and
nothing's going to make us leave and the
idea there is that this is in fact not
just about any particular policy it's
about building a poll for lots of
different policies and that maybe this
could be sort of an ideological place
and a physical place to actually act as
an amplifier for not just any particular
policies but for a bunch of popular
economic struggles from the south
appease workers
from from anti foreclosure activism so
tomorrow two thousand people are going
to take Subway's to Jamaica from Liberty
Square to participate in an anti
foreclosure action and so that's sort of
one of the things that I think the
people that are in the that see this as
a democratization thing is like well
what we need to do is actually build
this to be much more political power and
do that by building alliances with all
these other popular popular economic
distress fights and and then over the
long haul we'll be able to ask for like
changes on lots of different policies
not just the policies of today how much
time do I have I'm doing fine so so the
other thing that's kind of interesting
about this is also the very organization
of the square and the very organization
of the square it's not surprising anyone
who's read on a rant or somebody sort of
sees that that this is kind of the basic
structure of self-governance that
emerges during times of political unrest
so they're Soviets in some places and if
you say Soviets too loudly in liberty
square e or like people will get very
very mad but but it's kind of like that
self-governance and this kind of
directly democratic institutions or
something that pops up during moments of
a political mobilization like this and
then what I think the though you know
the the wild-eyed kids sort of like
about that is that it's that this is
actually suggests some putting even more
of the basic structure of the American
political economy on the table so it's
like how do you make decisions why do
you have representatives who gets to
vote in who gets to represent who and
who gets to speak for who and all of
that stuff becomes up for grabs and so
we renegotiate it all and we
renegotiated all day every day and you
know it kind of drives men mad but it's
a but it's kind of like exactly how you
take a bunch of diverse interests and
turn them into a general well as we're
sort of rethinking all of that and then
also economically it's that the way in
which the park were
is this strange combination of planning
barter and gifts and that in fact if
it's really sort of an exercise in
building it's kind of the anti anti
Machiavelli in some ways and like if
this idea that if you build a
constitution for people that you think
of as mean-spirited and selfish that hey
they'll become mean-spirited and selfish
but if you actually design a little
space that you're expecting people to
enter into on the basis of reciprocity
and and frame it that way then in fact
you'll get a whole lot of people that
are quite willing to approach this as
like not a place where they're out to
maximize their self-interest but rather
a place where they're sort of working
for some common end and what's
interesting about this is that it's
working despite the fact that the
population is constantly in flux so
people come in and go out and it's
always the same different phases so it's
not just kind of the enlightened
self-interest of the small community
that's staying like in permanent
relation it's in fact that when you
enter the space you're sort of taking on
a whole different way of relating to an
economy and I think David Graeber is in
multiple ways kind of talking about this
in the right in sort of the the right
frame that in fact there's a whole
diversity of economic structures that
are happening in the park and you know
and that tells you that the economy
isn't a monolith that's in fact there's
well there's lots of different things
you could do okay so what next so I'm an
economic historian and I generally think
you only see the clear picture kind of
long after the dust is settled so it's
really difficult to make sort of i think
really well informed judgments in them
in the middle of it so i'm going to hold
off on sort of the what next as a sort
of an economist but as a participant i'm
thinking that the goals are you know
hold the park through the winter hold it
through the next election cycle and hold
it in particularly in the face of all
the infiltration and all the repression
and particularly all the demoralization
so you have to just see it's like
there's a lot of people that are like
one more day and I'm out and so it's an
incredibly stressful environment and
there's just a you know it wears on
people and so keeping up that energy i
think is actually the the hardest thing
but then if you can hold it and it's way
too early to tell
um if you can hold it it'll wind up
looking like a pretty important set of
alternatives when all the things that
that it's attached onto and all the
energy it's it's created and it'll wind
up sort of you know look whatever
remains will be pretty pretty solid and
then I think we can start to talk about
real impacts so right now I think it's
still too early but give it a year let's
see what happens and then then maybe we
can we can actually see we see if this
has legs thank you well thank you very
much because you refresh my mind on many
issues concerning what they teach
generally but here is a kind of teaching
in the making now I would say that this
movement seems to me a a movement that
wants to reclaim representation
representation in in a very complex way
perhaps because on the one hand it is a
is true that his headless movements
doesn't have a leader doesn't have a
kind of party organization that is able
to present claim somewhere within the
institution or to whom within the
institution but it is a movement that
realize a lot about what's happened
inside of the institutions first of all
because of the contestation character so
there is a kind of demonstrations
against that those who are inside the
Constitution second because it is a
contestation of decisions made inside
the house constitutions in our names so
it is a claim of of representative
legitimacy in some sense and also
because it is an appeal to principles
that are common to those who are inside
those who are outside institutions in
some sense although not all of them are
consistent with with those principles in
the same way so one claim is a quality I
went through the web by when there are
several times I talk to people equality
is an
show it is an issue because it is under
threat it is under attack and it is
clearly in a ferocious retrieve in
relation to this famous one percent
which is very interesting because
generally oligarchy is precisely that
and you don't see it in action until you
don't see a decline in until you don't
see impoverishment among the many so
that they ask for intervention of the
state in order to change taxations to
redistribute at that point you see the
only be a few 1% otherwise you don't see
them because they don't need to defend
themselves in this moment they do so it
is an interesting example of fight
inside or democratic institutions
between an oligarchy which is never
never disappears in democracy is always
there and reappears regularly in moments
of great disadvantage disadvantaged by
those who are in the many and they can
be they become poor as I saw things to
say so in these moments they are very
dangerous for the one person few so
equality becomes a very radical form a
topic now is we used to talk about the
quality frequently all the time but now
the call for equality acquires a
different kind of meaning precisely
because it is targeted against those who
are always able to claim equality but
now they really don't want to share in
the fact of equality so it is a kind of
reconsideration of the foundations and
those who are in and those who are out
of the pack of equality is very
interesting and another issue that this
brings me to the question of
contagiousness movements are contagious
movements are not simply one drop in the
water it's one drop that creates circles
that creates waves so these movements is
a long time as a long history according
to me doesn't it didn't start one month
ago or so it started in many different
meetings of the ga
to g7 in the past years and then it
became very important with the Greek
with the Greek movement of december two
thousand eight and which was in the same
year of the election of Obama so okay
again a great interesting movement of
democratization which was completely
different from the kind of
democratization movement inside of
parties so it was a kind of self
promoted movements and and said glowing
movement and some in some sense and
finally they the spring the Arab Spring
at the beginning of this year and so on
so forth so there is a sense of
contagiousness but because the topic is
the same of course the topic is not the
same in North Africa as it is here but
is a call for in any case or against
despotic dominations in one form or
another one so it has the characteristic
of a protest movement wherever it is and
it has the characteristic of a call for
and democratic principles sir but i
would say that in comparison of
paradoxically and i'm very pessimistic
more than you perhaps because I'm I
don't know I like Machiavelli more than
you so I think that paradoxically and
this movement is in a war shape that the
movements in the growing or developing
or democratic movements in in the North
European countries although we don't
know the outcome of course we don't but
certainly they have a long way to go but
there is a way to go we really don't
know here where is the way to go where
is the day I know that is a question
that seems to be out of place now is
better to we live in the movement to be
inside of the present flux of movements
and energy I know that this is an
important fact that needs to be and this
is the
an empathic moment of democracy which
which is also an interesting to to
experience although if Lester and more
pessimistic than you because losing
these a battle which is a battle for
equality is a battle for redistribution
it is a battle for a different
conceptions of how we should put money
in the public or what should we do with
our money in government losing this
battle it's a well it's very very
terrible for the possibility for a
democracy not to become more immoral
lurking so the question does it's very
according to me it's very challenging
and and so this brings me to
representation again so this movement
was an attempt to edit is an attempt to
shake the institutions and show them
that there is citizenship outside of
them and this citizenship is not a an
enemy but it is the other face of the
calling of representation so when there
is a break of correlation or
communication between the two this is a
grave risk for democracy to decline in
one way or another way so it is an
attempt to ask for attention this
movement calls for an attention it was
to create a climate this is important in
the important faculty also was very very
good in them in writing that is creating
a climate attention to these issues for
any reason or another correct those who
are in the institution because they
don't want to add you know happy those
breaks and kind of social movements they
don't like them for for other people for
according to other reasons but doesn't
matter the intentions of the actors it
is important that these climate of
attention that can shake
institutions is here and so it is a
claim to be heard indeed this movement
it doesn't want to add unless I think
there is somebody who does know to
present a candidate for right there is a
candidate from Boston that she is
preferred yeah yeah so there is an
attempt to translate these movement into
something more stable inside of
dissolution this is not that because it
is a way of at least giving voice to
these issues which are important they
require important decisions than the
required simply mobilization they
require decisions and so it is important
that they find a kind of support inside
so it is an attempt and this is general
I have to say so where is in the
movements of North Africa there was not
these issues because of course there was
nobody there inside of institutions they
simply wanted to overturn the regime and
created these institutions here the risk
is to not to be listened to that is the
risk is that okay the newspapers they
tell us about every day about this wall
street but resources the strategy of
letting time pass by and people sooner
or later will get tired and so nothing
will happen so there is the sense of a
consuming energy sometimes and at the
end that this may hang producing this
effect of having this attention and
prospect that it can have I think so and
these are the kind of reflections that I
would like to share with you and finally
finally one um those who participate in
this movement said they come from
different traditions therefore the car
they are there and we go there for
different reasons and we don't have one
same culture sometimes we don't agree
either in the outcome that we would like
to achieve so there is no
military narrative there is no unitary
ideology person is only one which is the
negative 1 against or so it would be
very very good yeah there are that the
problem fall against is true because
equality so what our deliberations that
this movement is able to produce from
inside one is perhaps again bringing
back back equality inside of the
reflection about politics I come from
the part of political science and the
quality is far distance from our
interest much more intense more much
more people close to us is Liberty
stability conflict international and
domestic but the issue of equality which
is the breathe and the souls of
democracy is not there and recently
though it's very interesting there are
some signs that are interesting lyrics
to perceive recently though and the
American political science associate
Association I gave the award for the
best book of the year to a book called
the future of democratic equality by I
think Joseph schwartz which is an
excellent book and it is exactly claim
that we should back again go to a
quality because if we lose that we lose
democracy this is mathematical in some
sense it is also seems to be banal but I
think that if there is something
crucially important if his movement can
tell as is precisely that it may not
understand in all parts of the Americas
of the country and outside that there is
a process of these equality or
impoverishment which is not the same
thing as poverty is impoverishment
people who were well-off they are less
well of they will become less of so is a
question of decline and in this decline
the first thing we see it is precisely
the break of the contract or the quality
so I think that those are extremely
interesting issue
and we should just a couple of
observations about occupy wall street
los indignados i keep getting email from
spain saying we were there first you
know talk about occupying a space and
you know the ending nails in europe of
course i spent a lot of time in europe
and latin america indignados also made a
strong statement i find it extraordinary
because really there is a broader
landscape than what is getting picked up
in China there are revolts every day
there are more mobilize than the United
States is you have the picket arrows in
america latina with pots and pans the
instruments of the poor right and so
this is something that is happening what
Occupy Wall Street brought is let's say
the attention of the Wall Street Journal
the Financial Times you know those kinds
of things which is also very very
interesting when when I am when I think
about Occupy Wall Street I think that
one of its main most positive most
important most urgent outcomes and sort
of you know that the utility that it
produced is to signal to a very large
section of the United States population
that something is foundationally wrong
that it is not their individual failures
etc and I think that given a kind of
absence of critical culture in this
country if I may say that I I'm clearly
a foreigner but you know we foreigner as
we do feel that we're also Americans
how's that the fact of signaling you
know the ninety-nine percent one percent
great image is extremely important and
then beginning to elaborate giving some
basic information basic tools even you
know the way of transmitting means that
you have to keep it short and clear we
academics really suffer under those
conditions that this is an extraordinary
loudspeaker about basic ideas
that is fantastic now what I would like
to do is to to touch on three items one
is the question of Finance of course you
talked about finance too but I just want
to I would just want to lay lay out just
a few points of clarification that I
think matter and I hope there are some
use first what makes finance dangerous
it's not money we measure it in money
because that is one of the few means we
have to measure finance and you all know
by now the figures probably you know the
financial the value of financial assets
is 630 trillion dollars that is not
money that money doesn't exist global
gdp is 54 trillion so you get you know
14 times more than global GDP the danger
of and that by the way when the crisis
came 50 trillion disappeared in a second
and some of my students asked me where
did they go exactly they were nowhere
you know so when you think about it that
way it is like this complex system that
it is a system and systems are tough to
break down and it is multi cited system
it's far more developed far more
sophisticated than the multinational
corporations that's old format so for
instance you may or may not know there
is a company that owns the new york
stock exchange the the Bulls in Paris
the boars in Amsterdam the balls in
Lisbon and AH and Brussels there was in
Brussels now the boards in you know the
stock exchange in front foot is going to
buy the whole show the stock exchange of
Frankfurt is going to basically own our
adorable stock exchange now I mentioned
this not because it means that the enemy
really is Frankfurt clearly that is not
the reason but this is an extremely
sophisticated system it's you know it
wants to own everything under its own
keep it out there you know totally
network etc etc so we're dealing with
something that is structurally speaking
extremely advanced difficult to bring
down all the things we hear about the
net you know there is something not
everything about the structure of
Finance how it functions secondly if
finance is not about money what is it
about what makes it dangerous what makes
finance dangerous is that it has the
capacity to invade all economic sectors
all of them that's where the brilliant
creative classes come into the picture
and then of course make it all work to
its advantage so I always like to say
traditional banking institutions salt
money they had financed cells money it
doesn't have and therein lies its danger
because it means that it needs to invade
other sectors now I had a I had some
slides that I want to show it i don't
know how visible is better now let me
just keep on talking maybe a bit more
and so so we have been there before when
finance totally invades other sectors
etc etc we were there at the beginning
you know of the center of the past
century but I think today things have
gone to an extreme partly because of
things internal to finance high
frequency etc etc high frequency trading
but the only thing that I wanted to
bring out is the most really stunning
innovation of Finance is that it managed
to construct a very complicated set with
14 intervening transactions to make it
possible for a modest little asset to be
transformed sufficiently that it can
deliver profit to the high level you
know the secondary capital circuit as
they used to say in Latin America at
least that's Marxist language and then
we have of course the subprime mortgage
is an example of that and I've written
an article or I estimate what if this
singles global just because it fails
here or it is considered criminal here
as it is now that doesn't mean they
won't go global remember the junk bonds
they were considered criminal people
went to jail actually there was nineteen
eighty-four Wall Street the beginning of
our global era and then of course they
went viral globally but with a subprime
mortgage very destructive I don't want
to elaborate I think by
now the details are familiar this is not
about irresponsible consumers this is
about needing 500 contracts on an asset
in order to make it work so that is why
we have millions you may or may not know
the latest figures 9.4 million
households which could be each household
has you know one person he purrs and
five people we're talking a lot of
people ultimately 9.4 million households
are under foreclosure seven million have
already been thrown out of their home
the estimate given the contracts that
are already out is 14 million households
now this is a very big country so you
say 14 million households what is that
up to 40 million people what is it well
i am dutch my little country has 16
million inhabitants so that could be at
the limits three times the population of
the netherlands so these figures are
impressive and what does this system
have the United States or of vastness
and I don't know what it all is what
brings it together a capacity to render
so much damage invisible you know that
is a second danger in this system when
you have a little concentrated country
there is a way in which making visible
something is important this is why i
think that occupy wall street and
basically occupy like you know occupy
the United States occupy the Department
of Justice a source of a lot of damage
when it comes to immigration but occupy
wall stock you pie Wall Street occupy
the United States is actually
facilitating the communicating of some
of this stuff you know you are not alone
you're part of the ninety-nine percent
so I see a whole series of tragedies in
the making now I can't resist see if I
moving this right oopsie I don't know
how this it has so many options whoo
curve all you need to see is the shape
of the curve and so the first high point
the top ten percent of income earners
and
ten percent as other sources of wealth
at the you know 19 20 to 90 up to
nineteen forty to forty seven percent of
national income okay then we have 1942
to 1987 the adorable Keynesian decades
they lost chair they still have a very
robust chairman Zhu but it was 30
Clippers and rather than forty seven
percent and that's compelling at this
point or not then comes 1987 curve goes
up can we move to the next slide and
here you have and that is of course our
current and then you have this figure
from 1981 2207 the income of the top 1%
1% we're ten percent is to growth to
capture two hundred eighty-one percent
increase in their wages the then the
second you know the twenty percent of
including the top ninety-five percent
and no fifty percent of the population
in this country of wage earners barely
saw an increase these decades are often
this oh no that's too soon are often
described as very prosperous decades
it's text active checks it doesn't like
God you know and you look of course
gentrification makes it all look like
growth and beauty and all that already
happen so so these these kinds of issues
this capacity to produce both
invisibility about the many tragedies
and this capacitor preserve inequality I
know I'm one of my time so I want to end
with a final slide you see this is that
this is not Manhattan yet how the 10 10
years pip so what I want you to pick up
here is of course the notion of the
multitude that I don't
necessarily go there I want to see how
the powerless without guns without can
remark the most powerful apparatus now
in this case its military and there's a
larger question for me in all of this a
question that I've asked myself a lot in
my research drew the power loves make
history and they do take some often
three generations it takes them you know
many indirect possibilities they do not
necessarily become empowered you could
say that to here's where people they
made history they are still making it
they are not quite fully empowered we
know that too so that distinction
between making history and being
empowered because indeed in our angular
imagination if you are not empowered
nothing good has happened well I think
there is an in-between space of making
history and yeah I was going to say
something more way that maybe I should
shut up but so the final the final sort
of thought about this think of how very
powerful systems have come down the
Soviet Union the Latin American
dictatorships i was living in latin
america it was not a superior military
force that brought them down yes we had
soup really diverse in World War two and
World War one but for quite a bit of
history in many parts of the world what
bra has brought very powerful formal
systems of power down this is strange
mix that you can sort of from a distance
say it was the powerless making history
the abuse of power collapse from the
inside of the system now one thing is a
formal political system of power another
thing is an economic and especially if
it's a violent racism and that to me is
a challenge to think that through and
that is what I'm trying to think through
what are the vulnerabilities of the
system number one vulnerability it
abuses its own power and that's more or
less where we are at is this abuse of
its own power and all the you know it's
running out of where to grab money that
they allowed to know etc what are the
other possibilities that are happening
here Occupy Wall Street very important
and ultimately it's going to take work
by all of us and one image final image
we have to pull down the economy back
into our communities there is no such
thing as vertical you know we have to
keep relocalization conduction re
localizing the credit function etcetera
etcetera thank you three points to only
the last one hasn't been brought up so
go very quickly to the first to the the
issue it seems to me that though the
demands of this movement a our economic
demands obviously the one percent 99%
they think that is most important it
seems to mean we've all touch in
different ways is that it's the
political elements of the movement so
economic demands but at the cria the
thing in crisis and the thing that's
negotiated struggled for is a kind of
regaining the political space and and
regaining the political space first of
all from from the economic I think that
we can we can't disregard the fact that
whatever we call economic forces or you
know that kind of a abstract way will
real political power as such that is to
say not even necessarily through a
political institutions of course we know
how they work through political
institutions lobbying power essentially
buying out political power we know that
but I I'd like us to consider economic
forces as political
action a force of political action in
society and in a sense this the this
occupation hear this word I will use a
play around a little bit this were the
occupation of political space by
economic forces is also what is being
countered in these movements there is
something about the assembly movement as
such Suresh also mentioned that the
Iranian proposition that we know the
very very fact that that people come
together as such is in and of itself at
the most elementary component of
democratic action so part of this that's
the literal representation I mean a I
think nadia is bringing up a very
controversial the point that we need to
discuss because the movement itself
remember claims to be against
representation this isn't to say that
then we can simply disregard this
question in fact that relationship
between self-government self authorities
Asian unmediated democracies it's called
in the Greek term in the modern the way
that it was used in Greece direct
democracy and so on it's obviously
there's no doubt about the fact that
we're talking about a different kind of
political action that seeks to enact
democratic politics be on the ballot box
or outside of the electoral ritual and I
think that some of the wave to take very
seriously and I say this in full
cognitive how incredibly important the
right to vote is I'm not suggesting that
voting is somehow and not important but
however voting has become unimportant
precisely because of its ritualized a
way of being conducted therefore the
democracy cannot rely on the right to
vote as its primary right anymore
because on that basis it has actually
lost its political ground this I think
is is a key element of the whole
assembly movements and Lena okay
occupying the political space is one of
the ways of contesting the issue of
representation mind you occupy here's a
phase a funny
word I don't know if you noticed about
maybe two weeks after this happened in
New York and things started springing up
some people in this in the name of
Occupy Wall Street the same banners
produce this sign unoccupied for Jericho
which of course is really precisely the
point that's the point the yellow
portico is an occupied territory and to
occupy it you're right in the sense of
us and the movement is to contest the
notion of occupation by other forces so
Occupy Wall Street is a is an attempt to
in that same way to do to direct to make
visible I think this issue of visibility
is absolutely crucial to make visible
the invisible forces of occupation
across all spheres of the social and the
political but because decisions have to
be made as a combatant in a deist
demands put it on the table decisions
have to be made actions have to be made
this relationship between a mere
presence of assembly a mere presence of
people who by sheer presence alone make
visible that which has been rendered
invisible may not be enough as such or
at least I put it on the table as a
question i waver on this issue
philosophically I would like it to be
enough but i'm not sure if politically
it is the case because decisions have to
be made for a political action to happen
for politics to change for things to to
become different to be altered and who
makes decisions what decisions are made
and and generally the problem of
decision is something that we cannot get
around the last thing as you know some
grand vehicles i really want us to have
a discussion the last thing though is
something that that might deviate a bit
from the discussion but is I think very
important for us to think about ah first
of all there is no doubt about the fact
that we're talking about an
international thing we really have to
understand it that way which isn't to
say that we ignore the particulars and
the specifics and it and I don't know if
it's a matter of contagion that I can
contested people have argued the arguing
now in terms of resonance we can play
around the various paradigms whether
it's really liquid necessarily linked
directly or in fact waves I mean the
kind of global sense we can talk about
waves of resonance but the fact of the
matter is that it is international we
can't say its global that would go too
far I don't know what task you were to
say but but because it's an it would be
an easy use of the term that's why I'm
not saying it but it is global in terms
of what it engages with but this
international is happening a lot of
different places and even when it
recedes orissa code defeated it actually
resonates so we cannot even talk about
it being defeated although the practical
aspects of remaining in place against
all of the difficulties during
moralization but also the media danger
keep in mind the media is now are
playing up this thing however
reluctantly it can bury it adjust in
with extraordinary violence or media
violence at any point so that would be
something that we would face ahead and
this brings me to what I think is a
social component that to me is a
extremely important we we have no doubt
this is a global thing we have a
phenomenon that we can call really very
bluntly people in rage people are
enraged in across the globe in very
nerve various conditions they're not
they're not simply feeling a degradation
or or just simply experiencing the
violence they've been experiencing the
other at this point this has become rage
and this an indignation and the relation
between big national rage is one that we
can really perhaps think about obviously
the language we use here it's very
important not every language this
relation cannot be conducted formally
every language has a different insight
into it but the point I'm making or the
rather question I'm thinking about is
kinder be can there be a politics of
rage or what what is the politics is
there a politics of rage what would that
be can there be a politics of rage
how can we move from rage and
indignation to perhaps a kind of
politics of obsession kind of
empowerment what that involves so that
that asks us to think about other
actions that are not assembly movement
actions I know it's not popular to say
this in assembly movement circles but
even a cases where where people like
what happened recently in London just
sheer acts of Rage can not be considered
to be altogether other phenomena some
kinds of different of a different kind
I'd like to link those things and I
think that we really need to think about
the issue of violence the issue perhaps
anti violence which is very very
important element and finally the the
great question that is the Democratic
question how we move from a certain kind
of first of all how we move to a
withdrawal of consent moment because
that is what we saw in Egypt in Tunisia
very clearly we're not here by any means
in the United States not remotely
closely to that mode despite whatever
suffering people may experience or what
ever rage they might have how do we move
to the withdrawal of consent mode which
involves representation or perhaps not
that's a big if you can discuss and and
then if we get there I mean in Egypt and
in Tunisia they are there they did get
there how do we move from that to the
process of altering institutions to
instituting power which is I think the
key to to any kind of democratic okay
that's it for me the floor is open on
occupy wall street is a signifier on
what that might mean it seems like we're
constantly talking about Occupy Wall
Street as as a movement or a process but
it's also a collection of three words
that signify something and I'm not sure
quite what that something is also i'm
curious to think some about the ways in
which those of us who are
actively occupying Wall Street
Experience it sort of a constellation of
images and sound bites the sense that
something is going on over there that we
receive through either social media or
through other means it seems on one
level Occupy Wall Street is just the
generation of or the creation of um I
don't know content that we get through
through Facebook or the New York Times
or whatever else the other thing I'm
curious about is the sort of and maybe
what's powerful about the movement or
the signifier is the the fact that it's
still very open and undecidable I was
thinking when you were talking earlier
about an interview with derrida where
he's talking about September 11th and
what was so violating about that was not
that something identifiable happen but
rather that something happened which we
didn't know precisely what it was it
seems like a lot of the power of Occupy
Wall Street sort of the discursive
resonance of it and so on comes from the
fact that it's open and we don't know
quite what it is it's not quite
decidable yeah so there's not a direct
question here yeah but I'm sort of a
series of provocations if they're
generative please yes well i like i like
the notion of the signifier though
perhaps we can also drop that term
because it is a bit of that but i think
this is a point in a trajectory and what
you were saying people are enraged and
it's happening in many places around the
world so we did we do not know where it
all well with Greece which is truly you
know in the in the in the hair and the
Vanguard here and another thing under
the space of maximum confrontation it's
very interesting what's happening there
right and we don't know where it will go
and when I see some of the movements in
Latin America you know again so I have
the sense that occupy wall street is
more self-consciously
because you know you don't want to make
when there's no leadership it's and all
of that but I think as a movement as
something that transcends the particular
groups that are it also it's it permits
a trajectory you know we don't know now
I want to bring into our discussion post
1989 I mean or 89 in Europe right well
Eastern and and so you know the the
Soviet zone marches of people massive so
they were also occupied but it was of
course in the form of walking because it
doesn't start in Berlin you know people
think Oh them walk him down in Berlin I
mean we all know here right so in light
ticket started quite a bit before you
know it's a charge but the notion of all
these people walking millions of people
from Eastern European countries who went
towards the west and hungry help you
know whatever so we have interesting
instances of how a system comes down you
know and that to me the city if you want
to come back to signify the signifier of
Occupy Wall Street is that possibility
it is not a thing in itself and to me it
is articulated with all these other
movements you see there is a there is a
significant possibility that i have a
question for professor suresh since
you're an economic historian how do the
current process compared to the wall
street protests during the Great
Depression so actually it's interesting
because there's a little bit like of
this thing that it actually takes a
while for the depression to turn into
like sort of widespread protests and
stuff and it takes like organization and
takes people figuring it out and so it's
not sort of this immediate thing that
you have this economic shock and then
immediately people are out on the
streets which i think is sort of when
you're changing the Economist that's
what you think it's like oh yeah now
this is the best thing to do with your
time and and so so that you know it
takes some time and that what's
interesting then is how those movements
then feed into like the CIO or these
other organizations and then actually
turn into like policy leverage I don't
know how that's going to happen you
I have no idea but it's theirs they're
sort of some there's a bunch of
intermediate organizations between
people sleeping on the White House lawn
and that translating into like haha
unemployment benefits and how that
actually happens i think is kind of up
in the air i mean in the so we don't
have those side of connections that
existed in the 1930s that would
translate sort of that translated
discontent to depower into policy
leverage and that was the unions and
that was lots of work to mediate
organization so I don't know I don't
know how that happens now when you don't
have those institutions genzyme sort of
related but maybe not in an obvious way
one is regarding rage and the second is
regarding the passage of time the
passage of time I think I thought was
probably the one one of the most
interesting things about the occupation
only because the because of the
pragmatics human waste management being
sort of one of the most interesting ones
that that they're dealing with the idea
of just holding down for a very long
time and the idea of rage which which is
something that burns out and that at
times burns out in a flash and we have
to deal with the the sort of reality of
the day after the Revolution right what
how how do you how do you deal with that
um and in fact I think these two things
can can come together I think with rage
one of the issues one of the sort of
negative things I see about Occupy Wall
Street is the fact that you know there
was this woman who this this video that
went viral of this woman being maced
which is of course this terrible thing
but police brutality is something that
people in sit in inner cities experience
on a daily basis and not just at these
intense moments so so I think I guess
the the question or the provocation I
want to put forward is how do you bring
these two temporalities together I don't
think that that will provide a solution
but
but perhaps something to think about
yeah we thought that about a letter and
let's hear the questions and not yeah
just a quick reflection and a question
for any of the speakers well if we are
ninety-nine percent in our opponent is
one percent and we leave any democracy
there is a problem no so it seems to me
that one of the great things about the
caballo Street movement is simply that
if drinks to the attention is sheer
contradiction I mean if it's really the
case that the interest of the
ninety-nine percent of the population
lies year and the interest of the one
percent of ablation lies there and we
still you know we have a right to vote
we or less have an informed consent we
give informed consent of our
representatives there is a problem quite
deep in in the democratic system the
change of transmission of the popular
wheel to the representatives so I guess
that the question is simply how does
that happen I'm not a political
scientist but I I like politics so one
answer that I have is that in a sense we
are experiencing now the end of a least
30 years old age mo Ingram Shan
terminology which I mean Graham shipping
is the key figure in terms of legal
philosophy here to understand what's
happening now there is an anomaly that
made it possible for the CEO of the
multinational to make three hundred
times what I make and nobody seemed to
be outraged by that fact and I think
that it's only by bringing in these
ideology as you know something that has
become dominant and a demonic in certain
part of the word that you can explain
this contradiction of you know interest
of so many being on one hand but
then there was the political results and
representation going dressed in the
opposite direction and this brings me to
the final point I mean just I don't know
whether you want to react to that it's
nice to occupy wall street but in the
end wall street is in a sense of
financial private institution I mean why
not occupy the White House I mean I'm
what I have in mind is the following
it's clearly the gauge that this is a
leftist movement down in you know at its
roots Obama raised 1 billion dollar for
is new annex campaign so the the one
that seems to be the you know the leader
who says so these people are right is
displaying the highest degree of
completion and wishes overlapping
between political power and economic
power that this country has ever
experienced in this country is pretty
good at experiencing this mixture so the
the propagation I have is how do we fix
this problem of representation if our
closest leaders are so much entrenched
in this in this logic okay well we'll
take one more question and you do some
response and then continue but please
keep them short and we have to be sure
but you have to be short as well so we
have to end it yeah go in go loculi
we'll see how long people can take it
certainly we're go ahead hello friends
thank you for giving wonderful talks and
thank you everyone for coming there's a
lot to say so I encourage everyone to
speak and to continue these
conversations later if I try to respond
I mean I'm just going to go actually on
it not really a question but I don't
know if you have all heard but the
workers at sotheby's have been locked
out for 12 weeks that's 43 workers and
their families not getting paid for
three months of work and the reason
they're locked out is because management
wants to give them cut their hours
Cutler wages and all new hire ease not
have a you
in which I mean sell herbs made record
profits this year and their CEO gets
paid sixty thousand dollars a day so the
reason I'm bringing this up here and the
reason it affects us is because the
chairman of the board at Sotheby's who
has the power to end the lockout is
actually a professor at Columbia Michael
sovereign who used to be the president
of Columbia is now the Chancellor
Chancellor Kent professor of the
Columbia Law School so I'd like to just
pass around a petition if you'd like to
sign please do quick disclaimer when you
sign it I'm then going to send you an
email just one email with a URL to sign
the change.org petition so that then we
have all these signatures in one place
but I'll just pass these around no
pressure thank you so much okay um I
wanted disick thing about a rage okay
there's this isn't protect ability to
rage okay in terms I know that's kind of
strange that I said but but in terms of
political action in the streets and I'm
you're going to use the Greek experience
as an anchor because I know that the
best the way that a rage is expressed is
about now that with a but by now the
police knows it very well and I can
handle it by either hitting back or
waiting for extra distantly dissipates
in effect controlling fully the
battleground so so then what would you
get you get a march on the Parliament
some people get enraged there's you know
sometimes you a lot of war on the
streets things get broken people get
into it sometimes people get killed in
then the next day weapon another day
neck you know
next morning until the next time it
happens and so on and so forth in fact
the police in Greece was were befuddled
by the assembly movement precisely
because they didn't know how to respond
to it until of course they went in there
and completely trashed the place but it
took them about more than a month to
figure out how to respond to it
precisely because they could not predict
the movement so there is something about
the unpredictability or the you know
peculiarity of the assembly movement as
a leaderless movement that's that is an
issue the of course it is a symbolic
thing occupy wall street then in
technically speaking this is really
about ideally you know not in this city
but in every city every public space
should be occupied you know your local
square your part that force from your
house look what you can come we know
with your family in Europe and your kids
I mean what people can really literally
acclaim a certain a space public space
in the name of a certain kind of
political action Occupy Wall Street is
really definitely a bollock thing and it
really will mean nothing unless we're
talking about number I mean it's all
about numbers i mean ninety-nine percent
but we certainly don't have ninety-nine
percent the streets obviously so that is
a kind of stupid thing to say but but it
really an innocent unless a sort of
thing to say now as far as police
brutality in this city particularly ok i
didn't get that question are spoken was
really it's a really correct question
why is it that but you know there's a
whole issue about the fact that oh what
a wall street movement might be too
white there's no you know the whole
racial issue is a big discussion there
why are people you know who experience
brutality on a daily basis you know for
I you know years decades and so on so
forth why should they come out and so on
the from a second standpoint is totally
to be expected April I I on the other
hand I thought people who were
relatively privileged relatively
in relation to people who are
disenfranchised and people who are
victims of racial equality it's at our
inequality cetera it's it's perhaps
about time for them to be a little bit
at the forefront ah you know and maybe
get you know I took a pepper sprayed or
whatever I mean you know if you cannot
stay in your home and you know
complaining lament and if a movement
grows then of course you will see people
who are otherwise for various reasons
don't want to be police targets and they
may not be coming down if the movement
spreads in a particular neighborhood
specific neighborhoods throughout the
city you will see more people and so on
so forth so I think this is how this has
to be looked at not sort of a lamenting
the fact that you know it's a I don't
want us to go back into all kind of a
lefty radical politics or divisions I
think that's just something that we
really have learned from and get it
around yes yes on the question of
representation in general first of all I
don't think but here we cannot open a
conference or a seminar now that
representation is simply electoral
delegation because Alexia delegation
this is very complicated I don't think
that this is so quickly simply going to
put your ballot this is not
representation you create an electoral
institution or an elected mandate but
the representation implies a firm
political participation by the people
who want or don't want to participate in
any case and those who are inside of the
system is it's not simply dual or is not
simply delegating so it's not even the
opposition against represent
participation and the other one is where
instead is very interesting because I do
think that the question of hegemony or
ideological a change of language
whatever and we are a victim off because
we are inside of this system we don't
even recognize you just do also with the
sense of
I mean there are docility we are the
side they were terribly the side we also
the way in which we use our languages
and almost too as for to be to be sorry
for this reaction to be due to ask for
to be we apologize for entering this
kind of conversation so there is a sense
of ideological dose realization that we
we experienced in the last yes in Europe
is the same until until recently to have
a movement on the city was kinda scandal
my god 82 so the injury then we if this
is the case then the work to do is a
really cultural intellectual Wars
ideology work and nice to do with them
going through the language of the
contemporary democracy and Western
democracy in particular the assumption
that everything is natural there are
there is a low of our rules inside of
the market organization that goes by
itself as if were not even human created
or artificial this kind of
naturalization of parts of our
disciplines or parts of our life is part
of this ideology yes of course I totally
in agreement with that okay all right
I'll be quick so I know that the
economic historian said that he wasn't
going to speculate but one issue I have
had since I first heard about this is it
seems like the complaints that this
movement have are largely existential so
that if we you know put on the screws
and we got the power that we all hope
that we're gonna get and they sat down
at the table and said what do you want
us to do you know would be like we want
you to not exist and barring the
anarchist stint there like bent on this
movement we're not ready to run a
country so i guess my question is how
much do you think if we get the power
that we're all hoping for how much
should we play the game I mean is this a
third party I think we all don't want
the Democratic Party to capitalize on
all of this sentiment so I want to see
tonight just know where you guys see
that
going yes I guess I'm just wondering how
much resonance the movement actually has
in in general society I've I've been
living in Switzerland for the last four
years in Switzerland has something
that's very close to direct democracy as
a system and Dave notoriously voted very
conservatively and have just recently
failed to approve stricter regulations
for the financial sector and in a way it
makes you be disappointed in this whole
concept of direct democracy I guess yeah
hi thank you for being here tonight I
have a comment and not a question so
that'll shorten our time so I've been
staying at Occupy Wall Street since the
fourth day and one of the things that
I've observed being there and being part
of the community is that for me my
experience of community members has not
been one of rage where people are
irritated and irritated and irritated
and it finally turns into rage and then
they show up in the streets what I found
being a part of the community for months
now is that the environment is more one
of fear and being afraid and that coming
into the park is an expression for a lot
of people of I've been sitting at my
kitchen table scared for years and
finally there's a place to come together
and be afraid together for a minute and
then suddenly feel very courageous and
and I think the significance for me of
Occupy Wall Street isn't one of an
expression of rage I'm not enraged but I
have been very afraid for my future in
my family future and I think that that
the transformative experience for me and
a lot of people in Liberty Square has
been one of discovering a lot of courage
in each other and and also one of giving
ordinary people especially ones who have
felt very powerless lately their first
experience
of yes direct democracy but also that
heroic impulse for the very first time
and I think for me that's the most
powerful thing about this movement is
that we have ordinary American folks who
are having an experience of heroism and
feeling like they're a part of history
and whether or not we get too cold and
give up which I consider every night at
about 4am I think that that experience
that kind of getting hooked on heroism
for the first time is going to be really
transformative hopefully for our society
so thank you for being here I've a very
simple a question and very practical one
at the same time what do you think will
be the effects on the upcoming elections
that there is a movement protesting and
public space will it be a different
campaigning than four years ago thank
you I just want to say something about
the representation and democracy sort of
various comments but one of the sort of
cultures that that I think we try to
encourage down there is it like that
active participation is what is like is
what democracy demands it's that it's
like you need to actually step up and
talk and and be part of working groups
and do stuff and that that's sort of and
you know and that makes it a problem
sometimes because often you're dealing
with a bunch of people that come through
because they want to see it and then and
then they have the same voting rights as
everybody else and so you're sort of
yeah this is these are internal struggle
the other thing though was that I wanted
to say on the flip side of that active
participation just on the last comment
was I mean that sort of shared heroism
thing is partly that I mean I'll just
tell story about like when the threat of
the eviction on the Monday morning and
seeing these seeing like kids that had
never been politicized until like a
month ago to like look at each other and
be like are you going to get arrested
yeah
I'm going to get arrested and like being
terrified and deciding to go ahead with
it and so I mean that's pretty that's
pretty great and that's also the kinds
of social networks that are formed in
this that are going to last well after
this has gone away and so even if
nothing happens in Zuccotti square and
that it goes away there's like a whole
bunch of ties and stuff that will go on
ten years later and find themselves in
various institutions and they'll have
these links and know how these and
they'll have this sort of stuff and the
one of doing fabulous things and so even
if it even if it doesn't do anything
else it'll have it'll have set that up
so I hate yeah that's it so yes I think
I think that they these movements will
have an impact on this election it will
be very important in fact I we cannot
make prediction or whatever but you
perceive that they attack against the
movement by the tea party people they
are you know the other side of the story
from my very very populous t point of
view and very also reaction a point of
view so yes I think it would be very
relevant those it is relevant that has
not been
criminalized by by the by the Democrat
by the Democrats some of them they are
silent other of them are very splitted
supportive other of them are skeptical
but there is no no strong or explicit I
and this is an important fact also
because i think that is general i mean
if you count the numbers and numbers are
so important in democracy it's the
supporter to this movement is a huge
inside of the country so they cannot
simply a governor against the entire
people's it is a conceivable so I I
don't know that the outcome but
certainly the relevant to this movement
is out-and-out well two or three very
quick points I think that what happens
in Occupy Wall Street and our our one of
the people who spoke is the active
making of capabilities of the social of
the political you know and this question
of our political system is not about
politics in the good powerful sense of
that word it is about sorting and I
don't know administering and controlling
and invading a lot of invading so out of
that making of capabilities of making
the social comes an enormously
significant possibility for indeed a
future you know because it is not just
sitting it's not just demonstrating
secondly the fact that the concern is
about the social this is not about
grabbing power this is about remaking a
society you know and and i think that
people in the united states are
beginning to feel ontological insecurity
your average nice burger poorer you know
that the the census has shown very
dramatic new york city for instance was
always a city a machine to make wealth
and there was always concentration of
wealth in 1980 the top 1% obtained
twelve percent of all the income
generated
new york city in 2009 latest census the
top 1% takes receives grabs choose your
word forty-four percent of the income
generated that's just income we're not
talking wealth I think this spreads like
wildfire in terms of an ontological
insecurity there's too much grabbing at
the top so interesting possibilities
finally democracy is not just about
elections we need to democratize our
institutions that is the work that needs
to be done and that's going to have to
cut across a lot of areas and starting
with the executive branch of government
the Department of Justice you know I
have a few a list of favorites ah yes
yes I'm in light of the comment about
the Switzerland I I mean you know
there's nothing good about democracy
democracy about good okay it's not bad
morality or or or or utility of course
also nothing bad i mean in any kind of
inherent sense if anything as you as you
are no and this is you know i'm saying
saying something commonplace it is a
very dangerous system very unstable
system and can easily manipulate it but
it is in the end if we're going to say
anything about it relatively to other
modes of being a political act or all
right the freest and most equitable
system because it ultimately presupposes
everyone's participation whether they
are politically minded or not
politically minded whether they're this
or that or the other it makes no
difference in that kind of equivalence
regardless of difference is the key to
democracy but there's nothing good about
I don't want I I by I mean that's the
very first thing that one has to say
it's not about value it's really about a
certain way of being a political actor
meaning a person of the police in in
your own society so that you are freer
so that the law isn't is not something
that's made by somebody else that it is
made by you and there are four
interrogated
and so and support because even the law
you might make and the best democratic
tradition maybe a very unjust name and
has to be reconsidered and so and so
forth so I think that it's
democratization or at all levels of both
institutional but also the social ways
of being is really the key and I
understand that that's very abstract but
everyone who actually has been through
these things is that one time or another
knows what it's like to be there with
someone else that you don't know that
you've never met before and be part of a
certain kind of altering a situation
even if it seems insurmountable so I do
think that's what that's what it's about
I mean I definitely wanted to thank the
students are organized this event this
is really again the key to what happened
here and and this is not AI really I
know this is not going to be the only
thing and whatever happens is really
something for you to think about and
organize and move from here I so I
suggest that somehow you connect if you
haven't really if you're meeting with
everything before and I know me I know a
lot of people here we know and so but
still definitely reach out to each other
and continue the conversation outside
this room this is a very artificial
environment and you know though it's
everything is happening out there okay